[Music]
carlos is not sleeping well as the IT
manager at a large enterprise he's
responsible for delivering end-user
applications across a very complex
dynamic hybrid IT infrastructure as they
strive to provide clients with a better
user experience he and his team are
finding it difficult to keep up with the
accelerating flow of trouble tickets the
team is working harder than ever but the
tickets just keep coming faster with
more frequent rollouts of new apps and
updates now planned how will his team
keep up if only he could proactively
manage issues before they begin to
impact end-users IBM's hybrid IT
operations management solutions can help
you get efficient get proactive get
organized and deliver a superior
end-user experience with IBM hybrid IT
operations management Lee the first
responder in the operation center no
longer faces a sea of red the events are
filtered so she immediately sees the
event that is probably the root cause
and its impact she creates a ticket for
DevOps with the adoption of runbook
automation Lee can immediately see if a
run book is associated with the problem
event and then execute the run book to
resolve the issue guided or automated
run books can be shared across the wider
operations team to resolve problems
quicker Carlos the IT manager is already
sleeping better at night he sees that
the team has moved to a new level of
efficiency and has the metrics to prove
it
ramesh the SME has powerful cognitive
insights at his fingertips
he is notified of a performance anomaly
with insights to help him proactively
investigate further he fixes the issue
and the system behavior returns to
normal before users are impacted ramesh
then creates a run book to address a
procedural gap
Carlos the IT manager uses alert
notification to ensure that the right
ticket gets to the right person at the
right time alert notification groups
include SMEs in the DevOps team for easy
collaboration to minimize user impact
and fix problems faster scaled your IT
operations manage your entire hybrid
environment manage an infrastructure
that is constantly changing transform
your operations management like IBM
customers worldwide you can trust I BM
technology to manage your complex
business critical hybrid IT operations